.
OKAY WELCOME TO THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE --
WE HAVE ONE BILL UP TODAY WE'RE
GOING TO START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE BECAUSE WE DO NOT AS
YET CLEARLY HAVE A QUORUM --
SO WITH THAT --
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR IT --
SENATE BILL --
SIX OR SEVEN BY SENATOR SKINNER
YOU MAY GO AHEAD AND PRESENT
YOUR BILL [inaudible]
THERE.
I WILL BE [inaudible]
THAT [inaudible]
WHEN [inaudible]
RAINY [inaudible]
THAT BILL [inaudible] FORTY
WELCOME LIMIT AB WORLD FINANCE
AND FREE WORK. FIVE YEAR SUNSET
[inaudible]
HARPER HIS [inaudible] THREE SO.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS?
DAN.
ELIMINATION OF LOCAL CLIENTS A
GREAT SPORT REALLY.
EIGHT SUNSET BASED ON THE
PENINSULA [inaudible]
RIGHT.
SIX AND HERE'S OUR FIRST
[inaudible]
PERSON WITHOUT [inaudible]
POLICY.
AND I APPRECIATED [inaudible]
IRAQ [inaudible]
HAD SPECIAL [inaudible]
POWELL [inaudible]
IS.
POLICE OBJECTIVE FORM OF
SUSPENSION AND AND HOW
SUSPENSIONS AFFECT.
MANY STUDENTS ABILITY TO SUCCEED
IN SCHOOL SO OUR PURPOSE HERE IS
TO REALLY HELP STUDENTS SUCCEED
AND YET ALSO RESPECT THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
STUDENTS ARE BEING VERY
DISRUPTIVE DISRUPTIVE.
AND THE REST OF THE STUDENTS IN
A CLASSROOM SHOULD NOT BE.
AT THE MERCY OF A VERY
DISRUPTIVE STUDENT AND SO THE
BILL ALLOWS.
FOR THE TEACHER TO REMOVE THE
STUDENT FOR THE FROM AND IT.
SO THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE
BILL.
AND I APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS.
AND WITH THAT --
I WOULD ASK THE COMMITTEE FOR
THEIR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU --
AS WE PLEASE ESTABLISH BORN.
O'DONNELL HERE O'DONNELL HERE
KILEY.
KALRA.
KALRA HERE MCCARTY.
STEINORTH STEINORTH HERE.
THURMAN WEBER [inaudible]
WEBER HERE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I THINK YOU
CENTER SKINNER THANK YOU FOR
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS HAS REDUCED
THE PERMANENT PROHIBITION ON
SUSPENSIONS TO PEOPLE'S.
IN K. FIVE AT A SUNSET AS OF
JULY FIRST. TWENTY TWENTY THREE
FOUR THE PROHIBITION ON
SUSPENSIONS FOR PUPILS IN GRADES
SIX THROUGH --
EIGHT SO THANK YOU --
THERE ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO WE
HAVE A MOTIONS. OH YEAH I NEED
TO HEAR IT ANY ANY SUPPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION SING [inaudible]
IF YOU'RE.
CAPTURE FOR THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BRAD STRONG CHILDREN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU --
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT I
APOLOGIZE FOR SKIPPING OVER
THAT.
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEN OPPOSITION --
DO WE HAVE A MOTION YEAR IT'S
BEEN SECOND.
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED --
MISTER CARN DOUG WEBER --
IN THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED.
DO PASS AS AMENDED --
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CENA COMES FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
WHAT?
PLEASE YOU MAKE CLOTHES.
I GOT A HAND SIGNAL BACK THERE
AND I AND I APPRECIATE THEIR
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE AND THE
GOOD DISCUSSIONS AND I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE WITH THE
AMENDMENTS.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S MY CHILDHOOD
CHIEF OF STAFF OVER THERE THAT.
YOU KNOW USUALLY TELLS ME WHAT
TO DO.
AND DOES IT WELL BY THE WAY --
SO YOU UP [inaudible]
THESE ARE --
YES KALRA.
IT PASSES AMENDED O'DONNELL.
AYE O'DONNELL AYE KILEY KALRA.
KALRA AYE MCCARTY STEINORTH.
STEINORTH NO THURMOND.
THURMOND AYE WEBER.
WEBER AYE. FOR ONE BILLS OUT FOR
ONE THANK YOU.
I'M GOING.
TO WELL WE JUST
[inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
YEAH.
BOB IT DIDN
.
WELL IT DIDN'T HAPPEN YEAH
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
VIDAK [inaudible]
SOME [inaudible]
OF SATURDAY I THEIR GOVERNMENT
[inaudible]
OKAY NNOVA [inaudible]
THIS IS [inaudible]
AGAIN N'T.
NOW [inaudible]
LATEST PUBLICLY [inaudible]
SERIOUSLY.
THEY HAVE THE THREE BILLS US
WHEN WE'RE